it's not like it's happening what you're
saying in the movies where it's like
it's just it's a movement at the Swift
quick [ __ ] child for some people
there's nothing better than putting on
your finest coziest sleepwear before you
head off to Dreamland but there's other
people they just let it all hang out
buts
boobs balls sleeping naked it's
debatable
I'm Keith and I think you should sleep
with some clothes on I'm Colin and I'm
not a goddamn Puritan team and naked
team clothes you should not sleep naked
let's get naked the case for clothes
well in my mind the case has already
been closed so let's say you have a
roommate let's say you live with other
people and you wake up in the middle
night you need water are you gonna be
just naked their thing is your body's
always churning out it's always working
so of course you're gonna part yeah too
easy solutions for that do your [ __ ]
laundry wipe your [ __ ] ass even just
a little boxer-brief it's gonna catch
them keep them out of that bed know what
I'm saying she's gonna help its guess
it's gonna help don't say no I would
argue that it's actually more
comfortable to wear clothes while you
sleep the more layers you have while
you're sleeping the more control you
have over your temperature it's easier
to take off clothes than to put them
back on if you're a pajama pal you know
you pick out some nice silky pajamas you
cook your way through it maybe you got
lots of silky pajamas you can put on
that's nice I want to create the optimal
sleeping experience and with that comes
control and the control of having
articles of clothing I feel like all of
your problems would be solved with just
another blanket
that's a blanket answer to a specific
problem yeah you can stack on more and
more blankets but it would uh Oh boohoo
Khan you're gonna boohoo me you're gonna
fool me right here right now you're on
camera
god forbid there's a fire because you're
looking for something to put on before
you leave I don't know how to argue with
her she just takes the children's way
out of every argument also have you
sleep with another person especially if
you see even like with your brother over
Christmas holiday you should not be
sleeping naked
okay okay you're not gonna sleep naked
with your buddies or your family like
obviously you make some concessions all
right I'm not an animal
is there anything on this planet more
comfortable than nothing
silk the sensation of being naked just
swimming in your sheets is one of the
greatest pleasures on earth have you
seen Eastern Promises they they're the
naked fight they're the best what else
does your bits and pits ever see the
light of day and have a chance to just
see the elements that is a cartoonish
argument you know it you sleep in a
crisp cold you wake up refreshed you
sleeping too much heat you wake up
feeling like you've been in the goddamn
laundry machine you sleep in a Chris
called you wake up a sinus infection and
that's the truth what most often happens
when I start the night wearing clothes
is I overheat and then in the middle of
the night I rage quit and I shed the
layers and I'm like oh I wish I'd
started the night like this because then
I wouldn't be drowning in a pool of my
own sweat right now it helps you get
confident with your body walking around
naked it feels good just feels good to
be naked I'd get naked right now if it
wasn't an HR violation okay sex is
easier this way when you're already
naked that's true but you miss a very
fun part of foreplay which is disrobing
the partner one less barrier clothes are
not the most tricky thing to get past
like right now I can get to my stomach
in a heartbeat overheating leads to
restlessness restlessness leads to
insomnia I would be getting so much
worse sleep if I was wearing clothes but
I'm deciding to put my health first and
my best interest first and do its best
for my circadian rhythms
we've had a productive debate today I've
learned a lot about Stephen I think he's
learned a little too much about me I
think the argument is I'm for an extra
barrier you should feel free to sleep
naked like me sleeping clothes it does
not impact you at all and you sleeping
naked would not impact me and let's face
up together keep it smooth no bunching
safety comfort and at the end of the day
relaxation you think that the fart is
the same as a poo poo Colin please did
you just do a Cosby that's right
that's a pavatt I got kind of sad night
I decide for The Cosby in the old
meaning of the word